in the war now turn to the war in
ukraine president zielinski is warning
russia not to use europe's largest
nuclear plant as a shield for its forces
amid growing concerns the fighting could
lead to a radiation leak dozens of other
countries say the presence of russian
troops around the plant posed a great
danger charlie dagetta traveled to areas
just a few miles from that facility
russian forces have been pummeling
residential neighborhoods here in
nightly bombardments killing civilians
in what locals call a campaign of terror
the indiscriminate shelling of civilian
areas is a tragic reality of any
front-line town the difference in these
attacks is they're being launched from
over there the site of the nuclear power
plant
at the shortest point it's only around
three miles across the denebro river to
the sprawling zaparisia nuclear complex
occupied by russian forces since march
it's now become a battleground with
russia blaming ukraine for firing
rockets at it in ukraine accusing russia
of using it as a launch pad and the
riverfront cities of marconettes and
nicopol are bearing the brunt of russian
assaults
nicopol deputy mayor natalya horbalit
how do you feel how do residents here
feel being so close to a nuclear power
plant
people are afraid she said everybody
here is afraid
this is just one apartment destroyed in
the bombardment residents here tell us
they only have about seven seconds from
the time of launch at the nuclear power
plant to impact no time for an air raid
siren no time to take shelter
a missile slammed into this apartment
complex just a few nights ago
i barely had time to jump into the
bathroom a visually impaired survivor
told us i thought the house would
crumble down on top of me
another woman in shock and left homeless
points to the ruins of her balcony it's
that one
the second one down what are you going
to do now
i don't know she told us
i don't know
the attacks usually happen at night but
we heard several explosions while we
were there incoming and outgoing
president zielinski has warned that any
russian soldier who targets the plant or
uses it as cover will be targeted by
ukraine's special forces gail
all right charlie dagetta reporting from
ukraine we thank you